[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález es un hecho
el partido oficialista nuevas ideas a
formación política del actual presidente
salvadoreño en nadie buque le ayudó a
conformar que él mismo ayudó a conformar
se alzó con la mayoría en el parlamento
de ese país centroamericano para el
período 2021 2024 según los resultados
oficiales de los 84 escaños 56 de ellos
serían para el partido oficialista
nuevas ideas los resultados en este
proceso democrático generan cierta
incertidumbre porque con la mayoría
absoluta buque le podrá decidir aspectos
claves como la el nombramiento en
entidades públicas como la corte suprema
de justicia la contraloría ya está en la
fiscalidad de ese país con los que el
mandatario ya ha tenido uno que otro
rifirrafe o enfrentamiento con una
mayoría absoluta el presidente podría
también emprender además reformas
constitucionales la llevó que le parece
nota
el rival político que se enfrente a esa
forma de gobernar que según la ong human
right watch y algunos analistas
internacionales afirman que bo que él no
tolera que critiquen sus decisiones o
acciones y hasta lo han calificado de
ser un populista autoritario mientras
que la revista the economist ha dicho
que nadie bukele se convertirá en el
primer dictador millennial de américa
latina' el mandatario salvadoreño tiene
una particular conexión con el pueblo de
su país a través de las redes sociales
se muestra con un aspecto juvenil muy
cercano a la población y sobre todo muy
directo en sus comentarios lo que se ha
reflejado precisamente en la popularidad
que supera el 90 por ciento una cifra
que cualquier político en cualquier
parte del mundo le envidiaría y ese
apoyo se veía reflejado también en las
urnas no son sólo 56 diputados en esa
asamblea nacional también son 145 a carl
alcaldías a nivel nacional 14 de esas
alcaldías son cabeceras municipales sólo
en el área metropolitana de san salvador
la capital tiene 19 alcaldías locales
evidentemente eso
nos están diciendo algo buque el poder
sin contrapeso es nuestro tema en el
debate de france 24 y para analizarlo
hemos invitado a emilio corea él es
diputado del partido alianza republicana
nacionalista arena quien se encuentra en
la ciudad de san salvador en la capital
de el salvador y también guillermo
gallegos él es diputado del partido
oficialista gran alianza por la unidad
nacional gana también es vicepresidente
de la asamblea legislativa de el
salvador les recuerdo que ustedes
también hacen parte de esta conversación
pueden dejar todos los comentarios y las
preguntas que ustedes deseen a través de
las redes sociales es un foro abierto
les recuerdo estamos en facebook y nos
encuentran también en instagram y en
twitter como france24
ese arroba xanthi logo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta es numeral el
debate
efe 24 pues tenemos ya el contexto y
tenemos a los invitados y el tema
entonces pues vamos a comenzar y
comienzo entonces con el señor emilio
core allí en la ciudad de san salvador
sr
korea gracias por estar con nosotros y
peligro
a esta frágil democracia salvadoreña con
tanta concentración de poder por parte
del presidente ma jin wook l
bueno tenemos un problema de audio con
nuestro invitado vamos a retomar más
adelante pasó entonces a guillermo
gallegos otro de nuestros invitados y le
repito la pregunta si está peligrando la
democracia salvadoreña con esta aparente
concentración de poder que está teniendo
el presidente nadie bukele
cuando estar de santiago es un gusto
poder conversar y bueno definitivamente
que la democracia en nuestro país se
fortalece todo lo que se ha logrado
hasta el momento ha sido en base a las
reglas que están establecidas por más de
hace 30 años en nuestro país elecciones
libres y democráticas en las que el
presidente del 3 de febrero del 2019
ganó las elecciones presidenciales
rompiendo 30 años de vivar bipartidismo
entre arena y el fmln y el 28 de febrero
hemos logrado una mayoría de casi 62
diputados entre ghana y nuevas ideas que
somos partidos que apoyamos la gestión
del presidente bucl ha habido una
participación del 51% de la población y
prácticamente han sido pues una votación
bastante aplastante versus el resto de
partidos políticos hoy se da una mayoría
bastante consolidada de un solo partido
político
pero recientemente aún todavía hoy en
día ha habido una mayoría de 60
diputados entre dos partidos políticos
que han sido opuestos a la gestión del
presidente bucl de compuesta arena y el
fmln que gobernaron el país por 30 años
nosotros estamos muy contentos creo que
la gran mayoría de salvadoreños está muy
satisfecho y por eso es esta votación yo
califico esta votación a dos años de la
gestión del presidente bucl es como un
referéndum en la cual la población ha
decidido darle ese apoyo contundente al
presidente bucl así es que yo
sinceramente no veo ningún peligro para
nuestra democracia lejos de eso creo que
se está fortaleciendo y sobre todo es lo
que los salvadoreños quieren en base a
votaciones elecciones de elecciones
libres no son solamente los resultados
de estos comicios que son muy dicientes
el señor gallegos sino que también la
popularidad del presidente que supera el
90 por ciento según datos recolectados
durante el mes de diciembre
dice mucho de la percepción que tienen
los salvadoreños pero también este
índice de popularidad es criticado por
muchos sectores de la oposición vamos de
nuevo con emilio corea entonces para
hacerle la misma pregunta si él
considera que la democracia salvadoreña
está comenzando a tener a ser amenazada
por esta concentración de poder que
muchos dicen que está empezando a tener
el presidente en el ebook él es sobre
todo después de los resultados de estos
comicios parlamentarios
al santiago buenas tardes buenas tardes
a los amigos televidentes de france 24 y
por supuesto de tu programa debate 24
bueno comentarte que lo que ocurrió el
domingo obviamente es un proceso
democrático la población hablo y a
nosotros como alianza republicana
nacionalista arena nos toca respetar la
voluntad popular respecto a tu pregunta
si peligra la democracia o no con la
concentración del presidente bucl y con
la concentración de poder realmente a
nuestro criterio sí y es que el hecho de
que él por sí solo con su partido
político tenga 56 votos 56 votos que le
permiten aprobar préstamos que le
permiten aprobar más endeudamiento que
le permiten elegir magistrados de la
corte suprema de justicia de nuestro
país 5 de 15 y para un periodo de nueve
años que le permiten elegir fiscal
general procurador general procurador de
derechos humanos miembros de la corte de
cuentas miembros del consejo nacional de
la judicatura es un riesgo es un riesgo
para la democracia pero hay que decirlo
nosotros respetamos la voluntad del
electorado
al final fue un resultado bastante
contundente nosotros cometimos errores
no supimos capitalizar no supimos leer
el momento y prueba de ello es que nos
toca afrontar obviamente una derrota en
las urnas que realmente nos ha dejado
sorprendidos porque por primera vez en
la historia reciente de la democracia
nuestro país es un partido político
alcanza y supera la mayoría calificada
de realmente la población se expresó de
hecho en nuestro país actualmente se
realiza el escrutinio definitivo donde
se van a ratificar los resultados
nosotros estamos preocupados ojala bueno
tú los citadas al inicio de la
entrevista que la revista the economist
habla de que el presidente que quiere se
podría convertir en el primer dictador
millennial está en mano de él realmente
qué tipo de gobierno viene lo que sí
tenemos claro nosotros es que con los 56
votos él tiene hoy por hoy más los 5
votos me parece que son del partido gana
que representa guillermo quien saludo
por cierto que pueden hacer
tanto cosas buenas como cosas malas y es
un riesgo realmente porque esa
concentración de poder el poder hasta
cierto punto cuando se concentra en una
sola persona puede ser dañino para la
democracia de un país nosotros estamos
preocupados realmente por el resultado
obviamente deseamos lo mejor a las
autoridades y ojalá sepan leer el
momento sepan capitalizar esta
oportunidad que les han dado los
salvadoreños y nosotros por nuestra
parte tendremos que hacer una lectura
intensiva y profunda al respecto señor
gallegos ya continúo con usted prefiero
preguntarle al señor emilio korea usted
habla que no hicieron una lectura
pertinente de la sociedad salvadoreña y
el momento en el que está que es lo que
está haciendo entonces allí bukele para
tener más de 90 por ciento de
preferencia por parte de los ciudadanos
según las encuestas y para haber tenido
estos resultados tan aplastantes que
usted como usted lo dice el pueblo hablo
democráticamente los este proceso
electoral fue avalado
x
[Música]
organizaciones internacionales y
nacionales que dan crédito que fue
desarrollado con total transparencia
y habla mucho de la situación de los
salvadoreños que es lo que ustedes no
leyeron que nadie bukele si está
entendiendo en los salvadoreños
obviamente nosotros cometimos errores y
hay que decirlo no nos supimos
capitalizar y leer lo que ocurrió el 3
de febrero del año 2019 cuando él gana
la presidencia común 1.4 millones de
votos sacando no una diferencia de medio
millón de votos ese momento quizás no lo
supimos capitalizar no supimos hablarle
realmente a ese 75 por ciento de la
población que gana menos de 500 dólares
creo que nos faltó de llevar con un
mensaje contundente por un lado pero por
el otro el gobierno bueno es una campaña
desequilibrada hay que decirlo el
gobierno con todo un aparataje con
medios de comunicación con una pauta
publicitaria impresionante para
promocionar al partido nuevas ideas y
nosotros por nuestra parte no contamos
con el recurso soft sin embargo
aunado a ello hay que decirlo el
presidente tomó la decisión de no
entregarle cierto recurso financiero que
por ley le corresponde a las alcaldías a
los gobiernos locales de nuestro
país durante 10 meses tampoco le entregó
la deuda política a los partidos acá en
el salvador
está establecido que los partidos
políticos reciben cierto cierta
compensación cierto monto financiero por
parte del gobierno para hacer su campaña
tampoco tuvimos acceso a nosotros a eso
por lo cual es una campaña bastante
desequilibrada sin embargo haciendo un
análisis hacia adentro hay que hay que
decir nosotros cometimos errores quizá
el principal error fue no haber no
haberle hablado a ese 75% de la
población que gana menos de 500 dólares
algo que el gobierno de una manera
astuta no logró hacer mediante la
entrega de paquetes solidarios mediante
la entrega de 300 dólares en su momento
al inicio de la pandemia supo vender esa
imagen aunque en el fondo todos sabemos
que eso fue una deuda porque todo ese
dinero que entregó el gobierno que
fueron cerca de 4.3 millones de dólares
en compensación a un promedio de 1.5
millones de salvadoreños más los
paquetes alimenticios son productos de
préstamos que nosotros le hemos
autorizado al gobierno del presidente
bucl
en la actual legislatura desde que
nosotros decretamos estado de emergencia
en el 14 de marzo del año pasado por
kobe le autorizamos al gobierno
salvadoreño que fuera en búsqueda al
mercado internacional de tres mil
millones de dólares para atender la
emergencia antes durante y después
obviamente el gobierno fue astuto
utilizó este dinero lo entregó supo
canalizar eso y ahí está el resultado de
seis personas una mala lectura que
nosotros hicimos del momento realmente
señor gallego su opinión al respecto
sobre esto que dice el señor corea de
una desigualdad en las campañas que
aprovecharon la coyuntura de la pandemia
de kobe 19 para capitalizarlo
políticamente y que faltó la entrega de
recursos a los demás partidos políticos
que dice usted al respecto
bueno en primer lugar yo quiero destacar
algo que el presidente hizo en los
primeros días de su gobierno fue romper
relaciones con venezuela
no quiere tener ninguna relación con la
dictadura de venezuela y con el
presidente de nicaragua no ha cruzado ni
siquiera una sola palabra o sea él es
distante de este tipo de gobiernos
autoritarios emilio reconoce que el
triunfo del presidente bucl tanto el
2019 como el 2021 ha sido en base
pues las reglas democráticas de nuestro
país si efectivamente no se ha entregado
ayudas económicas alcaldías y a partidos
políticos porque se ha priorizado los
pocos recursos los recursos que se han
tenido se ha priorizado en el tema de la
pandemia recientemente la organización
mundial de la salud reconoció a nuestro
país como uno de los países que mejor ha
atendido la pandemia afortunadamente el
presidente fue muy visionario en ese
sentido y tomó medidas drásticas en un
primer momento el cierre total no
entrada de
tránsito aéreo ni terrestre a nuestro
país al final pues nos han dado por un
resultado bastante positivo yo si no
creo que el presidente vaya a abusar de
esta mayoría que tiene hoy en la
asamblea legislativa él es un hombre
demócrata y que en base a la democracia
ha logrado llegar donde está y creo que
es importante que la oposición como
emilio lo reconoce también en varias
oportunidades pues el cese ustedes
conectó de la población yo invitaría
arena y el fmln a a que se puedan sumar
al esfuerzo que como país tenemos pero
si definitivamente yo no puedo compartir
con emilio de que la democracia en
nuestro país tenga un riesgo el que
tiene libertad en todos los aspectos ahí
en nuestro país desde que el presidente
ha llegado libertad de expresión todas
las libertades que como salvadores y yo
tenemos en base a la constitución
siempre se han respetado lo que cuesta
asimilar derrotas electorales y lo que
lo que de alguna manera también puede
preocupar a la oposición
clark de eso principalmente el perder un
elección si señor gallegos este voto
para terminar de analizar las votaciones
del domingo pasado es un voto castigo
claro que se mantiene desde los votos en
las presidenciales que le dan el triunfo
que le
y ahora con estas elecciones
parlamentarias es un voto castigo al
fmln y al partido arena por esos 30 años
en los que han sido constantemente
acusados de corrupción y donde vemos
personajes como el presidente el ex
presidente saca acusado de haberse
robado fondos públicos el ex presidente
funes exiliado en managua
bajo el amparo del orteguismo allí el
presidente el ex presidente flores
también procesado tal vez los
salvadoreños dijeron no más esta
alternancia y esto se mantiene este
hartazgo y quieren seguirle dando
continuidad a este proyecto de gobierno
bueno yo siempre he pensado que el
ghanés del presidente bucl a los 38 años
37 años de edad es quizás la expresión
de los salvadoreños de ese cansancio de
los partidos tradicionales que habían
gobernado este país
él fue el catalizador del del hartazgo
como usted lo dice diego de todo ese
cansancio de promesas incumplidas de
ofrecimientos nunca cumplidos por parte
de los diferentes gobiernos esto logró
también que la gente tomara como una
bocanada de aire fresco con alguien
joven alguien diferente alguien que
realmente supo conectar con la gente a
través de principalmente de redes
sociales
y nuevamente yo si lo veo realmente como
un voto de castigo a los partidos
políticos que de alguna manera en el
último año pues se unieron prácticamente
en contra de la gestión del presidente
por cualquier razón porque no estaban de
acuerdo porque podían haber tenido la
razón etcétera etcétera etcétera pero
todo esto que emilio menciona que el
presidente hizo durante la pandemia la
ayuda que generó el tanto económica como
alimentaria 20 la medida que tomaron la
construcción de un hospital muy grande
para atender con esto la gente lo fue
asimilando como que era algo positivo de
hecho es algo positivo pero siempre se
contó con con la oposición del partido
arena y el fmln ahora si yo lo veo como
un voto de castigo hacia de estos dos
partidos y como un apoyo al presidente
de airbus que le permitió correr allí en
la ciudad de san salvador de sumar votos
entre los parlamentarios elegidos de
nuevas ideas
más los del partido gana de conformarse
es a esa posible coalición que lo más lo
más seguro que sucede allí en el
parlamento el presidente evo que le
podría impulsar una constituyente que
podría llevar a una reforma de la carta
magna para para plantear una posible
reelección del presidente evo que le al
final de su mandato ustedes ven posible
ese escenario teme en ese escenario en
arena
a ver hay que decir algo santiago el
resultado del domingo generó un
desquebrajamiento a todos los partidos
políticos nosotros como arena
teníamos tenemos actualmente 37
diputados y pasamos a tener 14 el fmln
que es la segunda fuerza política tenía
23 y pasó a tener va a pasar a tener 4
ghana que es el partido de mi colega
guillermo gallegos tenía 10 diputados y
va a pasar a tener 5 psn tenía 9
diputados iba a pasar a tener 2 pdc
desaparece su participó perece se queda
con un diputado cambio democrático y el
no partidario desaparecen de la
contienda ahora si hay temor en el tema
de la constituyente nosotros realmente
lo hemos venido insistiendo y creemos
que atrás de todo esto podría haber una
intención de convocar una asamblea
constituyente el vicepresidente de la
república de nuestro país el doctor
félix ulloa ha manifestado abiertamente
que está trabajando un proyecto de
reforma a la constitución integral desde
el artículo 1 hasta el 240 y tantos que
tienen la carta
a nuestros países y está este proyecto
reforma él lo pretende presentar a la
nación el 15 de septiembre de este año
cuando se conmemoren precisamente 200
años de independencia patria acá en el
salvador y en centroamérica por lo cual
temas incluso la dejado abierta la
posibilidad de que temas como el aborto
como el matrimonio igualitario como el
ampliar el periodo presidencial como de
repente darle un rol político a la
fuerza armada puedan incluirse en este
cambio de la constitución actualmente la
constitución de nuestro país si se
quiere reformar santiago es una
legislatura que tiene que obviamente
aprobar una reforma con 43 votos y
establece la constitución que la
siguiente legislatura tiene que
ratificar el mismo texto sin quitarle un
punto ni una coma con 56 votos ese es el
proceso de reforma constitucional actual
en el salvador
ahora que que vaya a pasar en lo
sucesivo luego del 1 de mayo que tome
posesión la nueva asamblea legislativa
con 56 diputados de nuevas ideas
con 5 diputados de gana genera
incertidumbre genera temor genera
preocupación en un buen segmento de la
población porque de repente el tema de
la reelección que es lo que se ha venido
criticando y se ha venido cuestionando
podría estar latente hay una reelección
inmediata acá en nuestro país la sala de
lo constitucional emitió una resolución
que cuando un presidente quiere volver a
la primera magistratura del país tiene
que esperar al menos 10 años así que lo
establecido sin embargo en el temor de
la población de un buen segmento de la
población radica en que se quiere hacer
un cambio a la constitución para que el
presidente bucl le pueda continuar de
manera inmediata y por otro periodo eso
es lo que genera un poco de
inestabilidad ojalá que ellos sepan
aprovechar la oportunidad que les han
dado los salvadoreños y no vayan a
abusar de la constitución de la
república señor gallegos de usted
factible ese escenario de una posible
asamblea constituyente para una reforma
constitucional que aparte de plantear
una posible reelección plantee estos
temas que dice el señor corea que son
temas de la actual
en muchos países el aborto que en el
salvador es sumamente restrictivo y
penalizado hacia las mujeres
y el matrimonio igualitario que es una
discusión que ya han dado muchos países
en américa latina y que el salvador y
muchos países de centroamérica parecen
quedarse un poco atrás en esas
discusiones que hay ya a nivel
internacional
bueno santiago nuestra constitución
establece cláusulas pétreas es decir que
no admiten reforma alguna y entre ellas
está el tema de la reelección
presidencial incluso la misma
constitución establece que quien
promueva se manifieste o haga por
reformar la constitución para establecer
una reelección presidencial
puede ser bueno será sancionada con la
pérdida de derechos ciudadanos yo de
verdad que veo bien poco probable que
esto pueda suceder teniendo en cuenta
esta situación constitucional también
que establece que esto no se puede por
ningún motivo que se convoque a una
constituyente yo también lo veo bastante
difícil yo creería que el presidente va
a ser su periodo de 5 años posiblemente
después de él ganaría nuevamente la
persona que el pueda designar
después tal vez intentaría volver pero
si no veo esta posibilidad igual pasa en
a como me lo explicaba para que se pueda
reformar nuestra constitución temas como
el aborto temas como
el matrimonio balnerario personas del
mismo sexo tendría que reformarla esta
legislatura segura que está actual y la
próxima ratificar la no puedo decir que
la otra que tome a partir de mayo lo va
a ser hay una diversidad de pensamiento
incluso en nueva idea no sé cuál será la
postura por lo menos de mi partido es un
poco conservadora con esto con estos
temas que que mencionó que hemos
platicado
señor corea para esta nueva legislatura
en la que ustedes han tenido un poco más
de 10 14 diputados en arena para esta
nueva legislatura
como van a ser el bloque de oposición se
van a liar con otros partidos que han
hablado ustedes dentro de su formación
política para para la siguiente
legislatura qué plan tienen es bueno
comentarte santiago que hasta el momento
todavía se está asimilando se está
trabajando en el escrutinio definitivo
precisamente a esta hora mientras
nosotros conversamos en un hotel de la
capital se lleva a cabo el escrutinio
definitivo que va a dar por sentado los
resultados y decirte que nosotros como
arena no nos hemos reunido también
comentarte que tu servidor
lamentablemente no ha sido reelecto no
formará parte de esos 14 diputados que
estarán en la próxima legislatura sin
embargo los primeros pasos que tienen
que tenemos que dar nosotros como arena
con base a experiencias previas es
elegir un jefe de fracción o un
coordinador del grupo parlamentario en
una votación cerrada o una votación
privada que tiene que llevarse en los
próximos días a partir de ahí se va a ir
construyendo obviamente la plataforma el
rumbo que va a tener nuestro partido en
los próximos años obviamente
los 14 votos de arena bueno nosotros
damos por sentado que no contamos con
los votos de ganas o sea partamos de que
el bloque de nuevas ideas gana tiene 61
votos estamos hablando de que arena
tiene 14 y el pdc tiene 2 el fmln tiene
4 nuestro tiempo tiene 1 vamos tiene 1
pd se tiene uno realmente es realmente y
en términos prácticos es bien
difícil lo que viene para nuestro país
en la asamblea legislativa sobre todo
porque vamos a tener voz y voto pero
realmente a la hora de incidir ellos
pueden tomar cualquier tipo de decisión
incluso si nosotros incluso excluyendo a
los partidos políticos en todas las
decisiones o sea en la elección de corte
de cuentas como te explicaba en el nivel
de endeudamiento de hecho han anunciado
ya un nivel un paquete de préstamos en
el orden de 1.500 millones de dólares
que ya genera preocupación porque
actualmente en el salvador de vemos 92
centavos de cada dólar en relación al
pib si se aprueba ese endeudamiento que
han anunciado hoy estaríamos llegando a
los 97 centavos en relación al dólar
respecto al pib o sea tendrías un país
altamente endeudado y altamente
polarizada otra gran rápidamente porque
ya se me está acabando el tiempo el
señor correa ya retomó con ustedes
guillermo
sobre esta investigación que hay en
marcha por parte del tribunal
salvadoreño por ese supuesto acto de
propaganda que protagonizó el presidente
bukele el día de la votación eso va a
trascender como ven ustedes eso que
funcione para hacerle contrapeso al
presidente o no
honestamente no creo que prospere hay
que ser pragmático y hay que ser
realista no creo que prospere y hay que
decirlo es la segunda vez que el
presidente lo hace lo hizo precisamente
el día de la elección donde él fue
electo a eso de las tres de la tarde
faltando dos horas para que se cerraran
los centros de votación él apareció en
una conferencia de prensa
e instó al voto hoy el domingo hizo algo
similar y no tuvo realmente no tuvo
mayores implicaciones yo sé en términos
prácticos santiago no creo que esto
prospere te soy honesto porque realmente
lo más que puede pasar que le impongan
una multa a una multa que todavía está
en colores en la antigua moneda que
nosotros teníamos acá en el país y que
en una multa risible al final si al
final lo buscan al presidente obviamente
él puede cancelar esa multa porque una
multa risible que la que se impondría
señor gallegos lo decía yo en la
introducción de el tema
revistas como the economist dicen que
nadie porque le va a ser el primer
dictador millennial
américa latina' lo acusan de ser
autoritario de no respetar ningún tipo
de críticas por parte de la prensa o de
la posición o de diferentes sectores
como reciben ustedes estas críticas
considera usted que hay cierto peligro
que acumule tanto poder entonces el
presidente y me preguntan también a
través de las redes sociales si puede
volverse un peligro regional
bueno yo no comparto estas opiniones de
estas revistas
que pues creo que sin mucho conocimiento
de la realidad de nuestro país o tal vez
de referencia tienen conocimiento pero
una referencia partidizada o de un solo
lado de la historia pueda decir esto yo
creo que el presidente está muy claro en
que debe de privilegiar siempre la
democracia en nuestro país y bueno como
ghana lo apoyamos lo respaldamos pero
también nosotros estamos claro yo quiero
comentar que
nosotros estamos por ganar nuestro sexto
diputado de 10 que teníamos hemos bajado
a 6 vamos a aumentar 1 vamos dentro de
los 5 aumentaremos otro entonces
prácticamente los 56 que requiere el
presidente el partido nuevas ideas
prácticamente lo estaría perdiendo y
estaría sumando a ghana digo esto pues
porque es importante también que en el
mundo conozcan que que no hay intención
bajo ningún argumento el hecho de que el
presidente quiera manejar
autoritariamente nuestro país señor
gallegos para el cierre este estas
votaciones y este poder que va a tener
el presidente evo que le requiere que él
demuestre una gran madurez política para
manejar este país con prácticamente toda
la asamblea a su disposición y las
instituciones y sobre todo mantener la
institucionalidad del salvador sin verla
afectada cuál va a ser entonces el reto
inmediato que tenga el presidente bucl
de una vez empiece esta nueva
legislatura en el parlamento
bueno yo esperaría que cierre el
escrutinio final y él debe de ser un
llamado a todas las fuerzas políticas
sociales de nuestro país para iniciar en
la construcción o la reconstrucción de
un nuevo el salvador eso es lo que yo
creo y estoy seguro que él va a ser pues
poder sentarnos todos los que tenemos
alguna actividad importante como he
dicho política socialmente
económicamente los sexuales vivos de
nuestro país para iniciar un nuevo el
salvador
señor correa la misma pregunta para
usted cuál va a ser entonces ese reto
que tenga el gobierno de nadie bukele
teniendo esta conformación en el
parlamento las instituciones jugando a
su favor pero precisamente sin que la
institucionalidad salvadoreña se vea en
entredicho
bueno realmente
yo considero que el presidente buque le
debería debería cumplir el artículo 168
número 3 de la constitución de la
república que establece que él debe
velar por la armonía y la paz social y
también el artículo 86 que tiene que ver
con la colaboración inter órganos yo
realmente esperaría que el presidente
buque le tienda puentes de entendimiento
a todas las fuerzas políticas pese a que
aritméticamente no la va a necesitar
porque como hemos venido hablando a lo
largo del programa podrá hacer todo lo
que quiera en esta legislatura ojalá que
él como tú lo mencionaba santiago tenga
la madurez política y se convierta en un
estadista que deje de pensar en las
próximas elecciones y piensa en las
próximas generaciones porque al final yo
lo único que puedo desearle a los
unitarios que han sido electos es la
mejor de las suertes espero un proceso
democrático
nosotros estamos atravesando una
situación difícil hemos perdido bastante
diputados sin embargo hay que respetar
la democracia de nuestro país y mi
llamado al presidente porque le quería
que tienda puentes de entendimiento
y que basta de confrontación ya no
tendrá excusa gel para decir que se le
está bloqueando aunque no ha sido así
para poder ejecutar sus planes de
gobierno emilio corea y guillermo
gallegos ambos en la ciudad de sant
salvador gracias por haber estado con
nosotros aquí en el debate de france 24
ustedes también muchas gracias por la
sintonía pueden seguir dejando sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales siguen con nuestra
programación buenas noches
[Música]